hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher there's a very common message I
hear from teachers who I show you know
here's a here's a new maybe slower or
more flexible or more playful way of
engaging with a mathematical concept or
skill and one of the common things that
I hear from teachers is I don't have
time to do something like this I don't
have time to engage with this because I
have syllabus that points to race
through I've got registration for our
school needs to make sure they're taking
all of these boxes for everything that
is required of them by the syllabus
Authority and for me to be able to say
okay we'll look the curriculum is a
launchpad to generate mathematical
thinking and reasoning and creativity
and if it's not used for that it isn't
serving its purpose often the thing that
I come back to is as soon as we go
through that experience of yes we we
raced through five topics in five weeks
next year when you teach that student
again you are going to have to teach
those same five topics in those same
five weeks and you'll say you know did I
teach you anything last year it's like
well you've probably taught them
something but I don't know that they
learnt it and so my response often is
yes I know I feel that impulse myself
too you know I don't have enough time
for this but in many ways I don't think
we have time not to engage with these
things that give students a real
conceptual understanding a grounding
that's actually going to last into the
future and not just you know the ability
to step through an algorithm in a
superficial way to get them through a
test in a couple of weeks that then
vanishes once we finish
[Music]
you